JOANNA SMITH: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't
see API management
for serverless and
multi-cloud, then
stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This talk is brought to
you by Prithpal Bhogill,
the PM for Apigee, and Kelsey
Hightower, a DevRel demo
favorite.
It starts with
Prithpal explaining
some of the key advantages
of serverless, the fact
that it completely
abstracts away
the underlying infrastructure.
It enables you to be
agile, because not worrying
about that infrastructure
allows you to focus and iterate
on your product.
Serverless is perfect
for microservices,
which are easier to maintain.
And the pair are quickly
becoming the go-to solution
for new systems--
or monolith migrations.
And serverless has evolved.
It started with
Functions as a Service
and then resonated so
well that it expanded
into building full applications,
and now, serverless containers.
Oh, and fun fact--
a service is basically an API.
No, stay with me here.
An API is a contract
around usage.
Many service front-ends
are actually APIs.
You build endpoints, and then
someone else will access them.
APIs are the simplest mechanism
for connected data experiences
between businesses,
within a business,
and from a business to a user.
OK, so if the future
is microservices,
and that's basically
a series of APIs,
then we need to meet our newest
friend, the API management
platform.
With any API, it's important
to be able to simply accomplish
several operational tasks--
control and manage access to
the API, monitor usage quotas,
scale according to demand,
analyze usage metrics,
and track monetization.
So you see why API management
becomes a very critical
function as you start to roll
out more and more serverless
applications.
And this is where Prithpal
introduces Apigee Edge.
The analytics system
in Apigee Edge
allows you to measure every
aspect of your API traffic.
You can measure
operational details
like response time and frequency
of different types of errors.
You can find things that are
interesting to your business,
like where are people located
when they call your APIs?
Or which applications are
sending the most traffic?
OK, so now, in the talk,
Kelsey takes the stage
to show off what a
product like this can do.
He spends nearly 20 minutes
walking through a full example
for API management, which
includes Cloud Run, a simple Go
app, Curl, Docker files, Cloud
Build Apigee, simple IM auth
and XML configs, Cloud
Functions, and API proxy.
And please don't ask me
to list all these again.
My point is that demos
like these, end to end,
showcasing the variety of
frameworks and applications
you may be using together
is why we do Cloud Next.
So if you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]